so PCB but I'll just copy this down so
if my digress is wrong or something tell
me PCB is on this angle down here and
PPA is this guy over here you're right
with that okay so it really does fall
out very rapidly don't forget don't
forget you've got tangents right there's
a tangent up there you've got corns
you've got parallel lines okay the first
thing I look at honestly is the parallel
lines
okay the parallel lines kind of jumped
out at me because I don't usually have
parallel lines in a circle geometry
question I have chords all the time okay
but parallel lines not so much so they
seem I think going to be important to me
for instance one of the angles and I'm
after it's Kai ki young is on the
parallel line with this transversal
right so I see that by alternate angles
pc b is equal to CP i think is a team so
I have I had these alternate angles
they're on parallel ones you okay with
that but once you see the ultimate
angles over there this is an angle
between a tangent and a chord right so
being at that chord slices my circle
into two segments this angle is equal to
the one in the alternate segment and I'm
done that's it okay so two steps number
one the parallel lines he'll turn angles
secondly thank you do you have an extra
copy that's what um
secondly this is the hot upon the young
penguin the time segment okay now we're
ready to tackle this guy up here right
this song this is this thing you
now remember excuse me remember when you
see something like this right you're
really thinking about similar triangles
how did I make the jump into similar
triangles hey so rapidly okay like when
I see PB squared all right I see but
that's what length times another length
right I mean it just happens to be the
same length twice and then over here I
have three legs also multiply
a product of two lengths is this a
product of two days and another product
of two lengths is the same as a ratio on
a ratio I just have to divide through
now I don't know which one I need to
divide by okay clearly it's going to be
P be on something equals something else
on TV do you see that like there's
nowhere else for one of the PBS would go
so the question is which sign goes where
what similar triangles am I going to use
so if you think about you just had Part
A you just had part a that told you two
angles that were the same okay based on
these um based on these lengths then I'm
interested in like for example hey B
baby's heel and PA is here so they
didn't have it a triangle together do
you see that it's the only one it can do
in fact it's so important I'm going to
draw that one over there there's P B a
and just to keep things consistent like
seriously
colors are super power okay then that
angle that I know it in the other
triangle that gives me PA and PB which
triangle is PC in it's in this paper one
right out here
now ordinarily I would draw this
triangle just as it is have separated
out but in order to get my similarity
and make it easier to see I want you
orient them to the same way so see how
we've got this angle here it's double
green angle
okay so PCB I'm going to place so
corresponds to this so it's gonna look
like this right
pity C V and put my green angle in there
are you okay with that are you following
so far now I've got a pair of angles but
I need more than one pair of angles I
need to to get similarity which other
angles am I gonna do
is is a compliment right there but you
see that BPA is here but that's the same
as BPC because he's actually here on the
triangle right because I flipped them
horizontally the top angle is still in
the same spot okay so once you see that
look I've laid out for myself what's
similar triangles right which of the
sides that I got a car splint okay so
let's see I've got a PA in this triangle
the a move on P B these corresponding
alright and then what we're going to go
to next I have to use the PP again but
in this triangle this time right and
clearly it goes to pieces right and then
you just cross multiply and okay now
what did I do
that you didn't do okay I saw I saw a
couple of things right I saw as you see
this the bells should be ringing right
similar trails if not similar triangles
I actually full disclosure I looked at
it for 30 seconds before it's several
similar triangles because within circles
you get some the trainer's all the time
which we take advantage of and do things
like this even though there are no
similar triangles on here
there's similar triangles are kind of
implied right which is why the products
have intercepts on intersecting chords
are equal they do something just like
this right or likewise let's see you get
the same kind of thing happening here
again pairs of the triangles right and
then one more time most relevant to this
particular one if I don't have a pair of
sequence but I have one secant and they
tangent right a tangent is the limiting
case of a secant right it's a secret
where the two points intersect at the
same spot so if this is
this is a and this is B you get x
squared equals a times a plus B now when
you see that x squared there right I'm
like mmm that looks kind of sauce right
but I didn't see it
it wasn't coming up it may well actually
come out if I work around it if there's
a circle that's on here that just isn't
constructive I could construct it maybe
but I didn't bother because the similar
triangles just jumped out quickly enough